[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar optimizing cytokine analysis
choosing the right assay for accurate
detection and interpretation of cytokine
expression
i am sydney mcneill of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by biotechne to learn more visit
www.biodashtechni.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i would like to now welcome our speaker
laura hokem stone
senior research associate non-clinical
application specialist pre-clinical
research center university of minnesota
and scott hunter-opler phdc
dvmc pre-clinical research center
department of surgery university of
minnesota
laura scott you may now begin your
presentation
good morning
today we'd like to talk to you about the
importance of cytokine analysis and
pre-clinical research specifically the
impact of assay choice and study design
on accurate interpretation of cytokine
results
my colleague scott and i are your
speakers today we're both part of the
pre-clinical research center at the
university of minnesota within the
department of surgery directed by dr
melanie graham
our center focuses on developing methods
to understand immuno metabolism towards
innovative therapies for diseases with
high public health impact such as
diabetes obesity and infectious disease
we are also interested in identifying
the general reasons why animal models
often fail to predict human outcomes
and as well as providing solutions to
improve the accuracy of these models in
animal welfare
i personally specialize in the
development of in vitro applications to
support our work
including including essay
characterization development and
optimization
as well as enhancing translatability of
pre-clinical research to clinical
applications
over the course of this talk you should
be able to understand the elements of
pre-clinical assay qualification
describe how study imposed variables may
unintentionally impact cytokine
expression
recognize the utility of multiplex
cytokine analysis in preclinical
research applications
as well as learning what attributes to
look for in choosing the right cytokine
assay
cytokines are a common analyte of
interest in preclinical research
this is because they are critical
regulators of inflammation and immunity
they are indicators of health status
disease progression
as well as monitoring treatment efficacy
cytokines transmit intercellular signals
that are central to human homeostasis
and they play a central role in the
pathologies of many diseases
cytokine response is a target for immune
manipulation such as in the instance of
solid organ transplantation
and they're a very attractive target for
research due to their accessibility
they're highly abundant in circulating
blood so they can be
sampled during minimally invasive blood
draws throughout a study
when you decide to incorporate cytokine
analysis into your research it is
important to consider the pros and cons
of commercially available kids for
cytokine detection
first you need to determine what is
going to be fit for purpose given your
experimental model and your experimental
design
some of the things to consider are your
sample type will you be studying a blood
product such as serum or plasma
or something a bit more complex and
harder to get such as cerebral spinal
fluid saliva or urine
sample volume is also important is this
something you have in abundance or is it
something you need to take great care to
conserve
another important thing to think about
is whether you're interested in looking
at pathway analysis or some single or
just a few targeted analytes
if you already know which cytokines
you're interested in you might only want
to run an essay on just a small handful
of cytokines rather than wanting to
multiplex and look at
multiple cytokines on a pathway level
for your analysis
you should also consider whether you'll
be running in phase or batch analysis
in phase is where you would be running a
small number of samples that you collect
in phase along with your study
versus batch analysis where you collect
throughout the study and then you save
the samples to be run in a large batch
at the end
you also should think about your
anticipated detection range which i know
can be difficult in a lot of
experimental models
but you should be able to predict
whether or not you expect to see high
levels of inflammation and therefore
high levels of circulating cytokines or
if you think these levels will be rather
low and sensitivity is going to be very
important for you
once you've considered these elements
you can decide which type of tests and
methodologies you'd like to employ
to detect cytokines for your research
as i said before if you're interested in
a few targeted analytes a single analyte
elisa might be a good choice for you
these are commonly run
using capture antibodies on a coated
plate
um but if you want to look at a large
number of cytokines you don't want to do
this with multiple single analyte tests
because it will use a lot of time and a
lot of sample volume
so if you're interested in
either a screening assay or looking at a
large pathway level analysis
i'd recommend using multiplex cytokine
analysis
this is typically done with coated beads
that can also have capture antibodies on
them and can measure multiple analytes
at once
the other thing to consider with
multiplexing is that in some cases you
do sacrifice some sensitivity when you
multiplex multiple analytes so you'll
have to look into what type of
sensitivity you need for each of them
in our center we use multiplexing
analysis for our cytokine research and
we do this using x-map technology from
linux
xmap is stands for unknown multi-analyte
profiling and is comprised of four basic
components
these include biological reagents these
are the capture antibodies
microspheres which the capture
antibodies are bound to and are
co-incubated with your sample
specific detection instruments for
detecting your sample
as well as dedicated software for the
acquisition and analysis of your
cytokine data
xmap works using microspheres as i
mentioned before so these are small
beads that are coated with magnetic
particles
and they
are able to have multiple binding sites
on each bead so they can detect multiple
analytes
the magnetic particles allow you to do
magnetic separation which is really nice
because it eliminates the need for
filter plates or complicated washing
steps you can just use a magnet to
draw your magnetic beads to the bottom
and just dump off your washing buffer
when you do your washing steps so it's
really convenient
when you use this type of technology
with the luminex multiplex assays the
way it works is that two floor ports are
mixed at different ratios to keep to
create unique spectral addresses
each bead color is then assigned an
analyte to measure in the assay's
reactions and each reaction measures
multiple analytes in one sample
to do this your first step is to
co-incubate your sample with your bead
cocktail
where your sample will then bind with
the capture analytes
next you need to be able to detect your
bound analytes so you'll co-incubate
your bound sample
with a detection antibody which in this
case is a biotinylated analyte specific
detention detection antibody which will
sandwich with the analyte of interest
following a wash you'll add streptavidin
p
which will bind to the biotinylated
antibody and allow for detection
finally you will measure your bound
analytes using a dual laser flow-based
instrument
examples of these include a luminex 1 or
200 a flex map 3d or a bio red bioplex
instrument
these work similar to a flow cytometer
where your sample will be drawn up in a
single column and interrogated by the
two lasers
in this case one laser will interrogate
the label to quantify the number of
binding events
and the other laser will interrogate the
bead with the red laser to identify the
bead region based on your internal dye
concentrations
next i'd like to talk about how we use
cytokines in preclinical research
pre-clinical research is comprised of a
breadth of different experimental models
from in vitro to small animal to large
animal
when your research question is
interested in face validity
it's commonly used as something like an
in vitro or in silicon model these are
models that will capture a similar
physiology or phenomenon that you're
trying to capture
such as hyperglycemia or glucose
intolerance and these are typically done
with cells in a dish or computer models
next if you want to look at construct
validity
you'll want a model that has similar
underlying biology to look at the
etiology of the disease
these are commonly done with small
animal models such as mice and rats as
well as certain large animal models such
as sheep and pigs
however these models often fail to
translate directly to the clinic because
there are too many differences between
them and humans
when you want to look at predictive
validity so you want to look at how well
your model
will respond to a clinically effective
intervention or therapeutic agent in the
same way that a human would
that's when we want to bring in our
large animal models which in our case is
not human primates
we take great care to choose the correct
animal model for any of our studies and
we specialize in working with primates
and the reason we do this while in vitro
and rodent studies generally support
really important work with pathway
determination and mechanistic studies
nhps are used to examine practicality
safety and generalized efficacy with
high relevance to the clinic
the reason this these animals work so
well is due to their close genetic
relationship with humans
they have close similarity anatomically
behaviorally developmentally
physiologically and in reproductively
they also have a complex immune system
that is very close to humans including
conservation of mhc expression
these animals also have cross-reactivity
with many human-directed biologicals so
in many cases we can use the same
reagents that we would in a human trial
with these animals
they're also susceptible to viral
infections um so that can be helpful in
these studies
and all of these things together allow
us to create clinical trial-like
pre-clinical safety and efficacy studies
that allow us to parallel elaborate
therapies and outcome measures
for improved translatability into the
clinic
given the importance of our samples
and of our animals
i would like to talk about how we can
implement cytokine analysis while
keeping in mind scientific rigor and
reproducibility
in our case
we commonly do cytokine analysis and in
order to do this we want to make sure we
have an assay that works well and that
we can interpret accurately
so we validated a commercial multiplex
cytokine assay and we did this by
collecting serum samples from 20 naive
cinemalgous mechax and we validated this
assay across four separate plates
assay validation is comprised of four
major components the first of which is
recovery
and this is defined as
measuring the observed concentration of
an analyte relative to the expected
concentration
we did this by creating eight unique
serum sample pools made from a single
animal
and each sample that was then measured
neat
spiked with the kit provided highest
standard and spiked with a kit provided
mid-range standard
our acceptance criteria was recovery of
between 70 to 125 percent of the
expected value
and with that criteria 13 of the 23
cytokines passed
next we looked at linearity which is
defined as the observed concentration
relative to expected concentration in a
sample with a known dilution
so we spiked our serum with the highest
concentration kit standard and measured
it neat and also diluted at a one to two
dilution and a one to five dilution
again our acceptance criteria was 70 to
125 percent recovery of articulated
samples
and with this criteria 14 of the 23
cytokines passed
next we looked at precision both intra
and inter assay precision
and to do this we pooled serum spiked
with both mid and high range standards
and we measured these across four assay
plates
our acceptance criteria was to have cvs
that fell below 25 for inter assay
precision and below 20 percent for
intrasa precision
all of our analytes passed except for
tnf-alpha inter assay
finally we looked at sensitivity which
is the ability of the kit to detect low
range concentrations of
analytes to do this we took the lowest
kit provided standard and diluted it at
one to two and one to four to determine
the lower limit of detection and the
lower limit of quantitation
our acceptance criteria was that the
lower limit of detection was less than
or equal to the lowest hit provided
standard concentration
and with this criteria all 23 cytokines
passed
when you take these four elements
together you can create validation uh
criteria for your assay
from this 23 plex assay um all 11 of the
23 cytokines met all of our acceptance
criteria
seven were rejected and five passed
three but not all four of our criteria
so we consider them marginal and all of
this helps us to interpret our results
as we go through with our experiments
so given that criteria in mind
we wanted to look at how
how within subject variability looked
with this assay
we did this by measuring cytokine values
and repeated sampling from the same
subject on different days
and as you can see here there's a number
of cytokines that have really high
variability
but if you look back at our acceptance
criteria you will find that cytokines
that have these really high
variabilities correspond to our rejected
validation outcomes
so since we've done that work we now
won't accidentally ascribe the cytokine
value to being due to experimental
effect when in fact it's due to poor
assay performance
so the kid i was just talking about
um
overall after our validation has about
40
of the analytes falling within detection
range for us
and intersa cvs that are within five
percent are about 39
of
the analytes
so this is one that we were using a
number of years ago
a couple years ago r d systems
approached us to test their kit that had
more analytes and was made for nhps
we were interested in this
so initially we ran a kit and followed
the manufacturer's sop
and again we only had about 40 percent
of analytes falling within the detection
range we had really nice cvs 88 percent
fell within 5
we then partnered with r d scientists to
be able to optimize the assay
performance
and after working with them for a while
we found that we could increase the
incubation time with the sample to
improve binding we were able to do this
without increasing noise in the assay
and we also expanded the number of
points on the standard curve to improve
the accuracy of lower concentration
analytes
after working with these scientists and
optimizing the assay we now have an
assay with 83 percent of analytes
falling within the detection range and
97.2 percent of analytes having inner
assay cvs falling within 5 which is
really exceptional for a multiplex asset
like this
so it's with these partnerships that we
can really
optimize these to work for
our specific
application and our specific samples so
that we can have really reliable data
now that we've gone through validation
of an assay and
elements that go into choosing the right
assay for your cytokine analysis it's
important to consider intrinsic
variables that can influence your
scientific outcomes in this case we're
of course talking about cytokine
expression
with animal models these intrinsic
variables are demographic based so these
can include species
our center works typically with two
species of nhps these are
and rhesus macaques and through our work
we have found that both of these species
have different baseline
cytokine expression
so it's important to not just compare
between species but
think about which ones are included in
your in your work
next we want to look at origin
so our nhps are outbred
and so they have a lot higher
variability in cytokine expression and
genetic expression as compared to a
rodent model which is inbred for a very
specific genetic profile
one of the most important things to
think about is the sex of your animals
and having a balanced cohort if at all
possible
in your research
as many of you know both preclinical and
clinical studies are male skewed and
this has had a negative impact on just
our interpretation of a lot of diseases
and therapies
um
and so to illustrate that a little bit
more
we looked at the difference in cytokine
expression in our cinemalogous mechanics
between males and females
and you can see that there were many
pro-inflammatory cytokines that had a
significant difference between the sexes
including il-6 il-8 and il-15
there were also major anti-inflammatory
cytokines such as il-4 il-10 and cd40
ligand which were significantly
different between the sexes
as well as tgf alpha and il5 which are
involved in wound healing and other
roles
next we'd like to talk to you about
model imposed variables that can impact
your cytokine expression and for that i
will hand it over to my colleague scott
thanks laura hi everyone my name is
scott oppler and i'm a current graduate
student at the university of minnesota's
college of veterinary medicine where my
research focuses on enhancing scientific
rigor towards improved clinical
translation as well as improved animal
welfare
in addition to some of these intrinsic
factors that can affect study results
there are a range of model imposed
variables that can unintentionally
influence important scientific outcome
measures as well
certain characteristics of the lab
setting such as how animals are handled
the severity of the conditions they
experience in both their physical and
social environments may expose animals
to conditions different from the
clinical setting
ultimately these types of variables can
all have downstream effects on an animal
stress state which has been shown to
have profound influences on a number of
physiological systems
taking a closer look at the possible
effects of handling it has been shown
that restraint is capable of inducing
stress that can affect numerous aspects
of physiology including the immune
system in addition to having direct drug
related effects introduced by chemical
based restraint
in the example presented here an animal
experiences restraint based sampling and
as a result has a stress response and an
activation of the hpa access
this can lead to changes in vital
measurements and changes in the immune
system including changes in inflammatory
state antibody production cytokine
expression and immune cell distribution
throughout the body
in such cases it may become difficult or
even impossible to discern what aspects
of physiological status may be
attributed to a test article or disease
state being studied versus what may be
due at least in part to an
unintentionally induced stress response
the two most common types of handling
used in non-human primate research
include restraint based handling and
cooperative handling
restraint based handling is the most
commonly used type of handling and in
many cases is required by the fda in
pre-clinical studies
um restraint based handling can include
sedation or physical restraint such as
chair restraint
and has the and is less representative
of the clinical situation and has the
potential for stress or chemical
confounding of outcome measures
on the other hand the less commonly used
cooperative hand cooperative base
handling is widely implemented at our
center and involves training animals to
actively participate in aspects of their
own care
following successful training animals
develop a comfort level with handlers
and can participate in certain
activities such as voluntary limb
presentation for blood sampling and drug
administration
in many cases these animals learn to not
only tolerate and participate in these
activities but some develop an actual
appreciation and looking forward to such
events as an opportunity to earn treats
and an opportunity to experience
enriching activity
um importantly this type of handling is
more representative of the clinical
situation
and has on the less potential for
confounding of important outcome
measures
um to initially assess the differential
effects of handling method on one aspect
of physiology we retrospectively
analyzed differences in serum cytokine
expression from samples we had
previously collected from naive healthy
animals either cooperatively or sedated
in these figures the red bars represent
cooperatively handled animals while the
yellow bars represent ketamine sedated
animals
our analysis revealed a widespread
blunting effect by sedation on overall
cytokine expression
um the blunting of multiple cytokines
from shared physiological pathways such
as ielts 1223 ifn gamma and il-2
suggests a general systemic effect
of sedation on cytokine expression
this can have significant implications
for studies that rely on assessing
changes in immune response as it may
potentially either hide or overpower any
changes that are actually occurring and
during study interpretation
it's important to note that these
findings were from a one-time sampling
and handling handling event
whereas many other pre-clinical studies
require much more intensive and frequent
handling in order to perform required
sampling dosing physical examination or
disease management
some examples of these kind of studies
include 42-day safety and efficacy
studies 24-hour pharmacokinetic studies
and even routine disease management over
a much longer period of time
for one example
a diabetic model of a non-human primate
diabetic model may undergo a minimal
bi-daily sampling for blood glucose
measurements and insulin administration
in addition to more regular blood
sampling different intervals
as a result we wanted to investigate the
effects of cooperative handling versus
restraint based handling in the context
of an intensive handling and sampling
schedule that was representative of a
typical safety and efficacy study
to do so we did divided a total of 12
young adult non-human primates into
cooperative or chemical based restraint
sampling groups and allowed them to
follow an identical sampling timeline
representative of a typical safety and
efficacy efficacy sampling scheme
animals were sampled initially
multiple times a week followed by less
frequent regular sampling for the
duration of the study
physiological changes in adverse events
were monitored further monitored for the
duration of the study and then were
compared across cohorts
the first thing that we found
was that chemical restraint led to an
increased
incidence of adverse events
the incidence of both vomiting and
nausea inhabitants were significantly
greater in animals sampled under
chemical restraint compared to those
sampled cooperatively
an increase in adverse events has major
scientific implications and highlights
the impact of handling technique on
animal welfare
an increase in handling related adverse
events may complicate study outcome
interpretation making it difficult to
distinguish intervention-related events
from those caused by handling technique
and these events themselves may even
alter therapeutic efficacy
to take a closer look at the physiologic
influences of intensive handling
technique we compared serum cytokine
expression across the cohorts
and found that chemical restraint based
sampling resulted in longitudinal
changes in cytokine expression
in the figures presented here the yellow
bars represent cooperatively sampled
animals and the red bars represent
sedated animals
on day 0 7 21 and 42 across the study
and we found that expression of several
pro-inflammatory cytokines showed
significant increases over time in the
frequently sedated sampling cohort yet
remained relatively stable over the same
time period in the cooperative cohort
once again similar to before these
apparent effects of frequent or straight
based handling that complicate study
interpretation by making it difficult to
distinguish test article or disease
related changes from unintentionally
provoked physiological changes again
provide an example of how one model
model-imposed variable can influence
scientific outcomes
in conclusion cytokines are a valuable
tool for preclinical research that can
provide insight into changes in health
and disease status as well as
therapeutic response adding to this
value multiplexing cytokine analysis
provides the opportunity to reduce
sampling requirements and animal numbers
used in scientific studies it provides
the opportunity for pathway level
analysis of health status and disease
progression
to maximize the value that these assays
can provide qualification and
optimization of any commercial kit is
critical as it increases translational
accuracy of our studies
sharing refinements via open access
publications can lead to improved
science from studies performed across
the world
finally understanding experimental
variables both intrinsic and model
imposed and how they impact cytokine
expression are critical for accurate
interpretation of study results
we'd like to take a moment to thank
everyone who has made all this work
possible especially including our
animals used in these studies in
addition to the incredible staff and
students at the pre-clinical research
center as well as our numerous partner
labs institutions who contribute to this
work every day
thanks everyone for listening and we're
happy to answer any questions
thank you lauren scott for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask the question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what clinical applications are there for
multiplex cytokine analysis
hi
um when it comes to clinical
applications for this type of
multiplexing um it's probably not the
most practical for
you know a regular um surveillance essay
that you do with patients but where it
does come in handy
is um
as a screening assay for clinical trials
and development
um so
they can be really a good way if they're
done appropriately sort of how we
outlined in this talk
to give you really accurate data to
select a few biomarkers or analyze some
interest that you'd want to moder
monitor clinically
perfect thank you our next question is
how can small labs easily implement
assay validation
um yeah happy to answer that um
sometimes this work can look a bit
daunting especially if you're a smaller
operation
but the nice thing is is if depending on
the type of work you're doing whether if
it's not regulatory um and what you're
really concerned about is just getting
the best data possible from your assay
you can modify sort of what we've
outlined by thinking about what your
critical end points are and what's most
important to you for how the assay runs
and you can do this by running a single
assay with
some previously banked samples that you
know will be
have low concentrations and then maybe
your disease state or your treatment
statement will have higher
concentrations so you can get a feel for
how the assay runs at different ends of
the spectrum
and look at sort of your cvs and your
detection ability
perfect thank you it looks like we have
one final question
how do you know that the changes
observed in cytokine expression is due
to restraint induced stress
rather than interference from sedative
agents in the assay
great so um after our initial findings
related to the effects of one time
sedated sampling on cytokine expression
we thought it was important to make sure
that our results were not just a direct
result of ketamine related interference
with assay performance
um to do this we collected new samples
from several cooperatively handled
cinema list macaques and measured
cytokine expression from these samples
both neat and spiked with ketamine
from which we found no significant
differences suggesting that these
observed changes were likely not due to
ketamine direct ketamine effects or
interference with the assay itself but
rather some sort of physiological
effects
perfect thank you
all right we it actually looks like we
have one final question that came
through can we extend the result you got
from primate to rodent model in case of
restrained and cooperative sampling
i think you can to a certain extent um
[Music]
well the responses won't be the same i
think it's it's safe to say that um
rodents will likely have an effect on
cytokine expression due to stress
from either handling if they aren't
acclimated to their handlers or repeated
sampling or repeated sedation um well
very likely those effects will extend to
rodents but they might not be exactly
the same
perfect thank you so much all right
thank you again laura and scott for your
time today and for your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor and our sponsor
biotechne for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand lab roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
you